الفرح ان شاء الله بتصير فرحتين يتعادلون
والله الحمد لله على كل حال من الله كتب
كذا ااااه ان شاء الله نعوض بالمره الجايه
عندنا فرصه اللاعبين كبار
القتاليه المباراه اليوم كانت فيها شويه
يعني من ناحيه الاداء الفردي كان فيها شوي
ضعف لكن الحمد لله ان شاء الله نتخطه
وطبعا احنا نتفق المدرب المدرب كبير والا
قيمته ان شاء الله بيعوض وان شاء الله
المره الجايه ان شاء الله
قدم المنتخب السعودي حقيقه صوره طيب
اذا ممتاز همم ما حالفوا الحب اللهم لك
الحمد والشكر ما نزعل لان هم انفسهم اللي
فرحوني مباراه الارجنتين وفرحوا يعني
الوطن العربي باكمله تقدموا مستوى طيب
اليوم قدموا مستوى طيب لكن محاله اللهم لك
الحمد والشكر ولا زلنا نقول كلمه الامير
محمد بن سلمان استمتعوا استمتعوا قدموا
متعه كرويه واحنا الحمد لله راضيه
خساره تكون نسبه الحظ فعلا انت اديت كوره
الحظ ما هو اكبر دليل البلنتي هذا واحد
اثنين
الفريق البولندي لعب على اخطاءك وهذا ذكر
كره القدم لعب على الواقف ويعتمد على كذا
خطا
اذا ضغط على المحور
همم ثلاثه نحنا في اوقات ياسين ندور كوره
بدون فائده كره القدم الدقيقه تروح عليك
تاخذ منك مجهود بدني عالي وما تسجل هو
ياخذ طاقق اقوى منك
فهذه كره القدم فوز وخساره
انت الان راحت عليكم مره ثانيه باقي لكم
مباراه المكسيك ودائما اثبات كره لما تثبت
لنفسك انك لاعب كره لاعب للشعار عندك
مباراه الثالثه انا المدرب اقول له الشباب
الفريق المنتخب بدي الخريطه يقول له تلعب
اثبت الان شعرك احنا ما جايين نتصور ولا
جايين ناخذ كاس العالم نسبه كره قدم
منظومه كامله مبنيه بطريقه صحيحه
المكسيك لازم نثبت انه نحن شعار نلعب كوره
صحيحه الحمد لله على كل حال
ربك ما كتبنا الفوز
مباراه كانت فيها نديه
الشيء الافضل
هي كم من فرصه وترجمها الاهداف نحن اكثر
من فرصه للاسف يعني قصدنا راس الحربه ولكن
عندنا ثلاث نقاط وعندنا ما بقول المباراه
عندنا فاينل قدام المكسيك ان كنا نبغى
نطلع عندنا هذا
تفوز في باذن الله اذا الله وفقنا نطلع
لدور ال16 الجزاء واهدارك كل الجزاء اكثر
بشكل مباشر على مجرى المباراه واثر على
اللعيبه بشكل كبير لان كانوا متفائلين ان
هذا الركض ازاي بترجعهم المباراه لكن
لاعبين بولندا استغلوا الفرص بشكل كبير
يعني شفت الفرس كيف كم عرضتين بس الحمد
لله الحمد لله ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
يعني املنا كبير في المره الجايه باذن
الله الضغط ولا زاد
شوف همم
الشباب فريق اللاعبين المنتخب
وانا اتوقع ان شاء الله انه يقدم الكره
حلوه
[موسيقى]
جواد واحنا ما احنا مستعجلين على دور 16
كل تاخيره في اخيره بنتاهل عن طريق بوابه
المكسيك ان شاء الله
ثقتكم بعدها كبيره بالتاهل
تكون عندك ثقه هذا مشكله فيك انت ان شاء
الله بتصير فرحتين
الله يعطيكم العافيه يا شباب